by the end of one division wada
maximov's reality flipping chaos magic
will have grown
so chaotic as to open the pandora's box
of the marvel universe
flooding it with forces like nightmare
mephisto chathan
ghost rider that's right we're pissing
fire folks
[Music]
welcome back to new rock stars one
division is gonna unleash a new villain
upon the mcu and no eric
it's not zombie vision i know we'll see
we'll see he's a dirt bag
and he should be dead in my heart he's
always been dead because i don't believe
that robots or robots
wish to like by billionaires are alive
in the first place i'm tommy beck told
this is rogue theory
the bills are 3-0 we're happy everyone's
happy in buffalo
the show that brings you the wildest
nerdy hot tanks
you can't stop arguing about and with me
today is the mephisto
of missable detail eric voss eric hello
hi everyone we're one and two down in
jacksonville florida but we're coming
back it's a long season
romania uh midshipmania that's all i
gotta say about that
yeah also joining us today youtuber and
brilliant nerdy mind mastertainment aka
mtmt how are you
i'm great how you doing tommy and eric
and wait
i can't spoil the third person
third person you've almost ruined it
unless it's already been
and finally we got a first timer here on
new rock stars
comedy writer and host of the crush
fictionally podcast
kimberly trong welcome kimberly
i don't follow sports
is that there's a little city called
buffalo new york
with a football team with a heart as big
as an apple pie
and apples are also indigenous to
western new york not
indigenous but they grow there i used to
work on an apple farm
i ran away i told that story on an
episode of the big question
anyway let's begin one division will be
the first release of marvel phase four
and we know it will connect to doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness
maybe through a shared villain i'm
thinking
uh one thing missing from the trailer
though is an obvious antagonist besides
catherine hahn's evil witch laugh which
sent chills down my spine my question is
what secret villain
is one division setting up for marvel's
future eric why don't you start us
off okay uh yeah so i think the plan
from the beginning was to make wanda
maximoff the villain of doctor strange
the multiverse of madness back in comic
con a couple summers ago they had her
come out on stage and it's like are they
gonna be teaming up no it makes perfect
sense to be the bad guy of the story uh
currently in wanda vision based off the
footage we've seen
it doesn't look like she's fully in
control of her reality warping powers
but that warping for now at least seems
to be limited to her small
pocket universe bubble but by the end of
one division wada maximov's reality
flipping chaos magic will have grown so
chaotic as to
open the pandora's box of the marvel
universe flooding it with forces like
nightmare
mephisto chathan ghost rider that's
right we're pissing fire folks
uh to be more concrete with this
i think the uh trailer imagery is
showing wanda mid manipulation from dark
forces like agatha harkness mephisto
we've talked about this on the channel
before
it seems to be adapted loosely from the
avengers west coast comic run in the 80s
not so much
house of m as we expected it to be but i
think the house of m
is going to be worked in in a different
way so in the comic series i mentioned
mephisto uses fragments of his soul to
try to manifest wanda's kids uh he might
be doing the same
to help project vision back to life but
i think
this series is gonna end or at least the
season is gonna end with wanda losing
it all and uh yeah as i said we've been
talking about the house of m
adaptation but i don't think we'll see
the house of m ark begin
until the very end of these episodes the
season finale
so imagine after she loses it all
wanda's psionic meltdown will cause
all of reality beyond the bubble to
start to fragment
what sword is most worried about it's
spilling over well now it is spilled to
all of the universe that we know uh and
i think the house of m event as we know
it is going to take place kind of
between
one division and multiverse of madness
it's going to conclude
with multiverse of madness that's what's
going to write all the wrongs so i don't
know if we'll get the
whole no more mutants moment until that
movie
but one division is going to end i think
with the pocket universe blowing wide
open it's going to unleash
like a pandora's box all these demonic
entities throughout the multiverse
uh mephisto chathan ghost writer uh
dracula lady death like it's gonna set
the stage for
every dark uh supernatural sorcery thing
that
could exist it's gonna all start with
the seed
of one division uh and it may be now on
the avengers or
i kind of hope groups like the midnight
suns uh to take down these kind of
threats
uh and to put the lid back on this box
for now it's going to be on
dr steven strange to uh face wanda
maximoff and reign her in
oh i like it i like uh hot
damn eric yeah that was fantastic
any any anything that involves someone
taking pieces of their soul to make
their dreams come true
even for evil purposes isn't that
inspirational yeah
and i like it you know basically the
villain is coming from inside the house
it's the person we don't expect the
titular character is going to be our
villain
i like it eric uh this week all of our
all of our uh
rogues are going to be handed out by my
beautiful knifeform troll
uh wow put it back in the box
it's truly one of the most terrifying
things i've ever uh
received wow but i do love him very much
uh as i love all of my children no
matter how ugly they are
and this nightborne troll uh is going to
give you two rookies for that erica
[Music]
i hope those aren't blue spoiler alert
for laner
all right kimberly what's your theory so
we are in this
family sitcom world and why are we
talking about
family are we talking about perhaps
long lost family stay with me
so we've got a you know again we've got
a lot of nods to these like wholesome
family sitcoms you know
bewitched full house dick van dyke
but who is a family tie
to one of these pivotal characters wanda
or vision
um who just so happens to be one of the
greatest villains of
all time a magneto
oh [ __ ] okay i mean
okay look yes is disney like
hey we're not ready to combine x-men and
marvel
you know what that sounds like to me
that sounds like executive red herring
talk
to me they're trying to get me off the
trail
but i'm on the trail baby and the trail
is leading to
magneto and that helmet yes
it locks out telepathy but can it lock
out a pocket
reality that's a good question i think
we are going to see a family reunion of
sorts we're going to dive into some
family
trauma may i say and
open up a can of worms with magneto good
old
i mean father of sorts yeah it's
debatable
enter this world and wanda's gonna have
to deal with uh
her daddy issues i have no evidence
other than
it would be freaking cool wouldn't it it
would be really cool to introduce
magneto
and that is the thing that opens up
opens up this world
so anyway that is where i'm at daddy
issues magneto he comes in he's our
villain
hey wouldn't it be cool is plenty of
evidence here at new rockstar
i was about to say kimberly i know we
don't know each other well but wouldn't
it be cool is the basis for
every theory i've ever had on this show
so uh
i it works if magneto was revealed to be
the big uh
bad in the upcoming marvel movies set up
through one division i
i don't know what i would do uh heads
would literally explode
i would i'd be on the floor uh just
doing i guess crunches probably not the
knife
troll has decided to give you two rogies
as
troll well has a pet uh elk this is this
troll has a pet elk for those of you
that
i mean who rescued who there
i like to think they both rescued me
oh
manifest on your end were you warned
about this big gag at all yeah
well i've seen your videos
a big pine cone like the biggest pine
cone
i mean it's a very pretty rock the pine
cone has a brother
it's very pretty thanks
i like i like stuff from all right i
like stuff too
wonderful empty bring us home please
all right so we got magneto okay we got
wanda but i think we are all forgetting
a literal sub one
that was introduced in doctor strange
one
door
will be the secret of feeling of
wanda vision i think that and we need to
remember dormammu
is a multiversal being and one division
is setting up a multiversal type shindig
so i think
that dormammu because he's pissed about
his really bad bargain he made with a
doctor
you know a while back um he's going to
want to find a loophole
in his contract and his loophole
involves
wanda maximoff so she makes his pocket
reality that is
messing with the multiverse and then it
expands
and wouldn't you know it the mcu isn't
in the mcu anymore
and thus avoiding all of dormammu
and dr strange's contract so he's like
all right
now it's time for a multiverse of
madness i guess
because steven strange isn't going to
let me get away with it
so i think that either dormammu is going
to be using
wanda's body as an avatar to physically
walk through
the mcu or wanda is just gonna change
the entirety of the mcu house of m style
and which allows derma moon to just come
through because
we honestly we really haven't seen
dormammu as a villain
in the mcu yet he was a threat but k
serious or by saying his name wrong uh
right is was the villain of doctor
strange one but your mama was just like
i'm here but yeah i almost got it but i
didn't but
you might see me again and i feel like
dormammu is too big
of a marvel villain for him to just be
all right i'm here and then all right
i'm gone in doctor strange one he'll
he'll be back he'll be back
trust and believe so yes watch out for
that tricky [ __ ]
he's a freaky [ __ ]
trickiest [ __ ] i've ever seen i i love
it yeah i agree i
i felt like it was uh like a check he
was like a check
checked box in the first doctor strange
where he like he we've now included him
in the movies
yeah i felt unfulfilled there's more to
come also
as someone who's made a lot of bad deals
with doctors i just empathize with him
i get it i get it so uh yeah i'm on
board uh all three of these theories
touched my heart
uh and the knifeform troll has granted
you
two rogies as well yes
yes the troll is a socialist he gives
everyone the same
but will they remain will that remain in
round two we don't know
oh here's my rookies uh here's a copy of
uh miss marvel number one which is i
believe
wow first appearance of carol danvers as
a hero
if i'm not mistaken so there's that and
what's this
a copy of uh the first appearance of
spider-ham
oh that's weird
[Music]
incredible hulk number one as well
wow because his master is a loser
all right let's uh let's pay a few bills
now with uh
companies i'm very passionate about
companies that you could say
have changed my life thanks to our
friends at bluetooth for sponsoring this
episode i don't know specifically how
visions anatomy works and
how he and wanda are intimate with each
other but it doesn't take
mystical powers or a sentient robot
brain to know that we all want to feel
more confident in bed now if i could
phase through walls and hide from my
partner if things got embarrassing
i would have a lot more confidence in
the world unfortunately with me it's a
lot of eye contact and a lot of
apologizing
that brings us to blue chew which brings
you the first chewable with the same fda
approved and active ingredients as
viagra and cialis and those are the big
boys okay those are the hall of famers
so when you're messing with those guys
you know your pill works this is a
chewable not a pill
you can take them anytime day or night i
recommend all day i recommend a full
cycle of them
even on an empty stomach so you can be
ready when an opportunity arises and you
never know you could be at the bank
you could be at the park you could be
sitting in your basement wondering where
all of your life choices have led you
and why
you live with your parents still in is
that a leak and is the leak water
or is it a gas leak are you going to get
out of the basement or has this become a
[ __ ] for you now
anyway blue chew is made in the usa it's
prescribed online by licensed physicians
so you don't have to go to a doctor or
wait in line it's even cheaper than a
pharmacy and that works for me and they
prepare and they ship it right to you
in a discreet package and i say no shame
if i order blue chew i want it coming in
a package that's not discreet
i wanted one of those howling envelopes
from harry potter
i want them to write those in here
this boy's about to get sprung two
points for gryffindor
anyway so there's no awkwardness
no awkwardness beyond what you have to
deal with watching these episodes
and you don't need to leave the house
which i know for a lot of you is a
must-have
okay if you could benefit from
confidence where it counts blue chew is
the fast and easy way to enhance your
performance
there are more difficult ways more
ancient ways and those come with a high
price so just call bluetooth i'm sure
we're gonna have a code here in a second
right now we've got a special deal for
our listeners visit bluechew.com
and get your first shipment free when
you use the special promo code
rogue you just pay five dollars shipping
i mean five dollars for a little bit of
bang bang that's worth it right again
that's b l u e chew.com
promo code rogue rogue r-o-g-u-e
to try it for free now i'm going to jump
in here to thank our friends at
expressvpn for sponsoring this episode
too
there's a lot of vpn providers out there
you've probably heard of a couple of
them
and some of you may have even used a vpn
before but i like to do
research on sponsors uh do your research
because you're gonna get taken advantage
of by your vpn
if you're just a sheeple living under a
rock and i do
my research one research element that i
found that has changed my life
the only recommended brand of vpn that i
recommend to my listeners that i believe
in
is expressvpn i can say with full
confidence that expressvpn is
the best vpn on the market here's why
folks
expressvpn doesn't log your data lots of
really cheap or free vpns make that
money by selling your data to ad
companies which defeats the purpose of
using a vpn
xrcp and developed a technology called
trusted server that makes it impossible
for their servers to log any of your
info it's also
real fast which i know a lot of you are
like blah blah blah blah blah but how
fast is it well
i've tried a lot of vpns in the past
i've had a lot of data sold off
and i've taken a long time to have that
happen to me they're real slow
a lot of those things slow your
connection down they make your device
sluggish i've been using expressvpn for
years and my internet speeds are
blazing fast even when i connect to
servers thousands of miles away i can
still stream
hd quality porn of videos with zero lag
the last thing that really sets
expressvpn apart from other vpns is how
easy it
is to use unlike other vpns you don't
have to input or program anything
you just fire up the app and click one
button to connect it's so easy
even your grandparents could use it and
they're idiots
it's not just me saying this
it's not just me saying this wired the
verge cnet many of these other tech
experts rate xpressvpn is the number one
vpn in the world so protect yourself
with the vpn that i use and trust
use my link expressvpn.com rogue
today to get an extra three months for
free on a one-year package that's
expressvpn.com
expresscpn.comrogue to learn more guess
what everyone
the country is shut down emotionally
physically
economically but that doesn't mean the
holiday season isn't right around the
corner
jingle bells [ __ ] it's coming for you
and this year
we know that people are gonna be buying
more stuff online than ever before
if you're like me your parents are
certainly divorced and they've also
divorced
their neck spouses and that means
christmas cards for everyone the demand
is maddening if you're an e-commerce
seller
are you ready to meet the demands of a
record-breaking online shopping season i
bet you're not
well be ready with ship station ship
station helps online sellers of any size
get their orders out quickly save money
on shipping and keep customers happy and
you know what i always say
a happy customer is a happy person and
you can put that on a mug or a t-shirt
and sell it with ship station and it'll
get there fast
they'll get you the shipping rates
normally reserved for fortune 500
companies
i'm talking enron i'm talking pecs.com
i'm talking all the big boys that have
been thriving in this new
what's that i just said enron oh yeah
they're on the fortune 500 i'm talking
stark industries
i'm talking lexcorp i'm talking about
lexapro
i'm talking the printers uh lexcorp
printers uh it's the fastest easiest and
most affordable way to manage
and ship your orders just a few clicks
and you'll be managing your orders and
getting your product to happy customers
which as i've said
research shows will lead them to buy
from you again
shipstation works with all the major
carriers and their interface brings you
prod
brings your products together whether
you're selling them on etsy amazon or
your own
dark website that caters to the sickos
and freaks
you want a slug come to beckhold.com we
sell
underground slugs for everybody ship
station is the number one choice of
online sellers you'll ship more and less
time with the best rates available
and right now rogue theory listeners can
try shipstation
free for 60 days when you use offer code
rogue
make sure your business is ready to meet
the demands of a massive online shopping
season
get started at shipstation.com today
do me a favor click on the microphone at
the top of the home page and type in
rogue that's shipstation.com then enter
offer code
rogue shipstation.com make ship
happen here's time for our discord rogue
theory quick shout out to our patron a
tripper who won this week's discord
rogue theory with an awesome pitch about
the new nick fury series
announced for disney plus you can play
discord rogue theory 2
by becoming a picture of new rock stars
and joining our discord all right
that brings us to our next topic
the nick fury series marvel is releasing
a nick fury disney plus series featuring
a
gotta be octogenarian samuel l jackson
at this point still looks great
uh but uh yes i i agree he looks great
i'm just saying
he's very he's been doing this for a
long time
anyway so the series will be produced by
mr robot writer kyle bradstreet
and it likely won't come out before
2022. all right guys what i'm asking you
is what do you think this nick fury show
is going to be about
mt let's start with you with me okay
um i i get it tommy i mean nick fury's
black i'm black i mean
that's the only reason i did it
all right let's just make sure
all right the nick fury show let's talk
about nick fury real quick
all right so i don't know if you guys
remember but at the end of a certain
movie which is you know probably the
greatest marvel movie of all time but we
won't talk about that
the winter soldier um fury mentions that
he's gotta head to europe and he would
appreciate some help but uh falcon was
like
too lazy for that i'm out of here just
kidding up he was like i gotta hang out
with my best friend steve
but fury said he was heading to europe
to get rid of the remaining
hydra forces and i think that's exactly
what
this new nick fury uh disney plus show
is going to be about
nick fury heading to europe and fighting
none other
than everybody's favorite woman spider
spider woman whoa jessica drew
um and the reason why this i think this
is gonna happen is because there was a
certain
hydra commander based in europe by the
name of otto vermis
and otto um he's a bit of an [ __ ]
because he
he brainwashed uh jessica drew into
working for hydra
and jessica drew even tried to
assassinate nick fury
well she was told to assassinate nick
fury but she didn't do it because she's
a good apple
um but uh yeah i think that the sneak
fury show is going to
see nick fury in europe just like
spider-man you know everyone's going to
europe these days
it's great it's great it's amazing
leaning tower of pisa probably at um
the the paris tower which i'm forgetting
the eiffel tower all sorts of beautiful
places
i've totally been to europe as you can
tell
but yes i i truly believe that this nick
fury show is going to
be in europe and he's going to be
kicking hydra ass as he should because
hydra
kind of kind of not great people a
little bit not fantastic
uh yes i like the introduction of spider
woman
for sure i love any talk of europe i've
been to europe
over two times
i
[Laughter]
we're going to let the knifeform troll
take a break and he has been replaced by
a gorgeous uh piece of comic con swag
from like five years ago
a green lantern figure oh my god
this is a john stewart not hosting the
daily show
uh jonathan stewart running back
uh not him either this is jon stewart
the green lantern
jon stewart liked your theory so much
that he is awarding you he's manifesting
with his willpower
one rogie for your efforts oh my gosh
thank you great this is the first
appearance of the punisher
whoa yeah man what's
what is this behind it it's another
spider
oh my gosh and another spider ham
i have too
but yes thank you tommy my pleasure
kimberly what do you got for us i
have a much simpler theory for the new
nick fury show
and i think it's just going to be an
origin
story i think we're going to learn about
a young nick fury yes we know that
samuel
jackson is tied to the show but could he
be doing a voiceover
could they be working his magic and
making him nice and young again
although he clearly has not aged over
time so they won't have to do too much
don't crack him that's right unlike
robert de niro in that movie um anyway
she was so it was so old um anyway
that was cinema excuse me
uh no magic could turn back the clock on
that i'm sorry
but i love you robert de niro uh
so nick fury we're going to see an
origin story i mean we've got
when we saw captain marvel for example
we saw a younger
nick fury how satisfying was it
to find out why he wears the eye patch
right
he wears the eye patch because i mean an
alien cat scratched him
and that was so satisfying and i feel
like
disney's setting us up for more
satisfying moments like that where
we're going to learn just a little bit
more about why he's a bit
rough around the edges why he's this
kind of man of mystery maybe why he
wears a lot of black
leather who knows
the the sky is the limit with nick fury
so i'm looking forward to an
origin story i like that yeah i believe
it
that's very plausible great theory i
definitely was not thinking that i love
the idea of nick fury in a rough trade
store
picking out his leather coats just
thinking about battering someone around
with a pair of leather gloves maybe
having someone spit on them
maybe someone put a boot on his throat i
don't know different stuff that goes on
there
i've never been but uh you know i've
heard about it
okay john stewart is now floating into
the screen and using his willpower
he is also awarding you one rogie for
that
congratulations congratulations
yes wow
it's a map of the eastern united states
oh my god i don't even have to use waze
or gps i could just
if i'm ever in the eastern united states
just use this map absolutely just like
while you're driving unfolded on the
highway just
totally fine just drive and read the map
it's
totally safe you could head uh towards
buffalo new york
roll your window down and shout out into
joshua's front yard josh you're a god
baby
mvp stands through three games we love
you and then head back here
wouldn't that be great wouldn't that be
nice that's how i'm gonna use the rest
of this year
i'll write you a script if you need to
remember what to say those were
funny enough those were actually my
first words so that's just
crazy no kidding i hope they're not my
last words
eric what is your uh theory for us uh
okay well let's see uh well on tuesday's
video i talked about how this nick fury
series i think is going to be setting up
an agent's a sword
uh event and uh an adventure secret
invasion
film or series series i want to say that
as a mini series
uh more than a film it could be a film
um but the question with any of these
disney plus series
is what is going to be the newcomer
what's going to be the baby yoda twist
where it's like oh i didn't know this
was going to be part of it but i'm so
glad it is
and my in this case i think it's going
to be abigail brand
who is the commander of sword and i
think a lot of people don't uh know her
because it's from one of the more recent
runs of comics so it is relatively more
recent
but i think whoever they cast is abigail
brand is going to blow people's minds
i'm open for charlize theron
maybe lena heady i'd also be okay with
lena heady uh
but i just want some like uh uh a badass
lady of a certain age let's not go young
let's let's get someone in their 40s or
50s to do this please uh
and uh i think brand is uh going to have
this interesting dynamic this
interesting conflict between fury
because fury
in in my theory framework is relying on
a network of squirrel spies
he has been for decades uh whereas brand
is gonna be someone who
uh prefers to use the sword rather than
the shield
right she's uh an aggressor she wants to
point their guns out of the stars
preemptively strike other opponents to
them go after the cree
go after other threats uh before they
can come to earth whereas fury
likes to slow play it right with
earthbound defense with a cold war as
opposed to a hot war
so i think it's going to be uh that's
going to be the dynamic between the two
of them
um and i think all that's going to
change when the cree
uh you know reveal that scrolls are on
the planet i think that's what's gonna
spark the uh the secret invasion
conflict with the scrolls
um but i think what's gonna happen is uh
you're gonna see a subplot
with um monica rambo and taylor's
unnamed daughter
i'd love to see it if they were in like
uh maybe a friendship but maybe like a
romantic relationship right
like maybe there's some kind of
partnership where that's like her scroll
double
and uh that could tie into the the two
monica's maybe we saw in
the one division trailer which could
just be an editing whatever but if there
are two monikers in that scene that
could be an explanation
i love it if this uh scroll princess is
veranky um that would be an awesome
reveal it would change a lot from the
secret invasion and the squirrels in the
comics but uh that could be an
interesting twist like where
this squirrel feels resentful resentful
toward the humans
when they start lashing out the
squirrels and maybe she could start to
lead the scroll resistance against them
and present like an interesting conflict
between these two friends but my hope my
hope is at the end of the day decree
suddenly retreat like they lay down
their arms and they
they flee back home and people are
wondering why why are the crews stopped
attacking earth
why are they why are they laying back
well we're going to find out that their
homeworld of holla
is being attacked by galactus
oh lord all right oh okay oh boy
oh boy all right i like it that's what
we call a thick theory
i lost track of where nick fury was in
that theory by the way
but uh he's part of this he's but he's
he's there
he's on a kite made of glitter
all right i like it and jon stewart
likes it as well
he says man i wish i was part of the mcu
instead of this stupid thing
and with that he gives you one rogie and
a million
and a million comments under this video
because i just said that
bring it on yeah can't wait
remember the my dislike for the dcu has
nothing to do with my physical
appearance so if you tie the two
together that's a you
problem it has everything to do
everything
all right everybody uh we've had some
action
we've had some adventure now it's time
to bring both worlds together
for rogue question okay this is
one question coming at you so fast and
furious
spoiler alert that you won't believe
what you're going to be asked
vin diesel released his first music
single and sadly it has nothing to do
with fast and furious yeah what the hell
i have listened to it more than once
on purpose i enjoy this song i was
pleasantly surprised
i think it's got a lot of heart i think
vin really tried his best
we're not gonna mock him for that but we
are gonna mock his ridiculous voice now
can you give me
your best impression of vin diesel
singing the next
fast and furious theme song
you know i'll go for i don't even know
what the hell i'm gonna say but let's
just go for it
okay all right let's go ah uh
go go club on the voice
you gotta go fast for a family you can't
go slow for a family if you go too slow
your mama's gonna know and be
[Music]
[Laughter]
um i have to bring my voice down
okay i think that's the best that i i'm
gonna be able to do um
get out of my dreams oh yes
get into my car get out of
my dreams that's it
i wanted more kimberly i wanted to leave
you wanting more
buy my single billy ocean in there very
nice
um for mine uh this is a vin diesel that
has forgotten that paul walker died
so you just see the song walking around
the set going
[Music]
oh god
[Music]
uh is the real answer was this is a
movie called the fast and the furious
fastest and the furious
the furious
[Music]
fast car's a big policeman the rock
going through a building helicopters
that go
on the water fast and the furious
all right the winner of this was clearly
mastertainment
oh my god thank you it was a three-way
tie until this round i forgot to tell
people that
you are a winner as our winner you get
to request
some sort of dare for all of us to do or
some sort of request
anything you want what would you like to
see from the uh panel today okay i
request i
demand tommy continue
singing diesel we'll do it as an outro
that's it for this episode of rogue
theory thank you to our guests
eric vaughn
[Music]
mastertainment don't forget to subscribe
to rogueterry podcast
and stay tuned to the youtube channel
for this and other shows follow us on
twitter at new rockstars follow all of
these fine people at their social media
handles
go bills baby we're gonna see you in
vegas where we take down the raiders
when i drive by super superfast car
and wave at my family
i go fast and commit robberies
the fbi can't catch me
this is a movie called the fastest